a lot of people like to you know what
what really bothers me
about the the cult of wokeness and
actually this is a good this is a good
point to segue into this
we'll talk about colin kaepernick and
the cult of wokeness they will buy
anything
if it is from the church and and i don't
mean that as in the christian church i
mean it is in terms of like their
new religion so first let me introduce
you
to calen kaepernick is back in the
madden game
which people thought was really
interesting because colin kaepernick is
not
a football player he's in the game he
left the nfl this is in 2016.
four years ago he got cut out and that's
that they took him out of the game
he's not great now he's in the game now
they put him back they put him in the
game with his black power sign
so scores a touchdown he does the black
powers he does that
is that black power well yes the fist
well it's the it's it's arguably the
communist it's revolutionary
yeah revolutionary but it's getting
co-opted by the oh it's the revolution
because it's like the fashion
yeah right yeah the fingers together
make us strong and that's why you show
the fingers to people
that's the black power thing too right
they would do that raising the fist
i mean you know it's it's a salute for a
right panther thing racial
they put it in a video game yeah that
was what was real
touchdown move in real life he just got
on the knee i guess
on his knee or whatever that guy he's
divisive how do you feel about colin i
think
he is a brilliant businessman who
realized
that this this is the let's just cut
right to the chase okay
why is he being put in this video game
first i think
you mentioned this sometimes they put
free agents in these games yeah they're
not on teams but they're prominent
players
and so they decide to include them it's
been four years
maybe he shouldn't be included but you
know whatever who am i to judge
he's he's a famous person who was in the
nfl he's not anymore
and if they thought it was going to work
for them so be it i don't care
apparently the game was terrible and
nobody wanted to play it anyway oh wow
but this to me is a really good example
of get broke
go woke not the other way around that's
what the oscars just did too
yes the oscars did this a misconception
among many people is
that every you know these companies
decide to embrace wokeness
because that will make them money so
they signed a contract with colin
gambling that it's going to sell more
games i don't know exactly what the deal
with
with madden was but nike has a big deal
it's like an all-star deal
where he's apparently some people are
estimating like five million with colin
yeah and and they're saying that this
deal is reserved for like the best
players in the nfl
he's not even signed no he's not a good
player either so but let me explain this
there have been some instances where
companies have made woke products
and then failed miserably and everybody
laughs and says get woke
go broke meaning something we've said
yeah and and i say it a lot if you
embrace wokeness you're going to lose
money
yeah here's what's actually happening
for a lot of these companies they're
losing money
so they decide to try getting woke to
make money you know why
hail mary have you ever seen a woke
comedy show
no these people here's how i can explain
regular comedy you're sitting there and
you got to say someone like ryan long
have you seen his videos
he's amazing he's hilarious we had him
on the show yeah right and so you're
sitting there laughing you're like
this guy's amazing this is so funny i
dude i saw there's an article from
babylon b
and it said new netflix subscription
service pumps raw
septic waste straight into your living
room and it was just people sitting in a
like a family sitting on a sofa laughing
and smiling and there's a pipe with just
sewage spraying everywhere
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen amazing
and it was like the ceo of netflix said
the industry is evolving and we're
evolving with it oh my god
people are really excited to pay 8.99
have raw sewage pumped into your home
amazing but here's the thing woke comedy
is like
did you see the white man with his
privilege get fired
and they go hahahahaha claps not laughs
clapter do you know what clapter is well
i'm starting to understand
that's horrible claptor is the idea that
people are clapping
not because you're funny because you're
saying things that confirm their bias or
they like
wow so like uh john oliver for instance
he does not make you laugh he gives you
clapton yeah for sure
it's so obvious too so he's sitting
there and he's like did you see the
orange man
he's so bad and then everyone's like
hahahaha
you are very funny i am laughing enjoy
it it's not it's not real
so what we're seeing is here's a
question that i asked and maybe this
will be offensive to a lot of uh
religious people
have you ever been to church only like
on easter a couple times and i got stung
by a bee
so all right would you consider it back
and you've definitely been in church i
have been to church for most of my life
would either of you consider it to be
entertaining it the one i went to was
not no
what about you um the one that i went to
it depended on the preacher i finally
found a church that was actually
engaging it wasn't entertaining
but it was engaging maybe what's the
point of football
to be entertaining to be entertained yes
to be part of a team
so listen i i asked the question why is
it that people go to
church even though it's not entertaining
to them
to learn because no it's because people
are going there to practice their faith
and to worship and to meet and share
with other people
right they're willing to go to these
services these services
and and to be fair i i these like
legitimate religions
with like scripture and real basis i can
respect someone having faith and saying
we're going to go to service
i've been a church several times and i
think there are a lot of churches that
do a really good job of being
informative
and interesting and engaging like you
mentioned yeah and i think it's actually
a problem that there are
there are a lot of churches that you
know they do try too hard to be
entertaining
well it's not so much they try too hard
it's that there are some that are just
you don't want to be there
yeah and especially young people don't
want to be there well yeah you start to
feel really guilty
and one of the things that i noticed
with church was that they well first of
all they would try to be too
entertaining and also people use it as
an exercise of discipline
so it is not meant to be fun it is not
going to be funny it's just something
right yeah discipline well so here's
what's happening in my opinion
when they put colin kaepernick in this
game
when they make a movie like ghostbusters
what they're betting on is
listen our company is dying we're losing
money
the ratings are down for all of these
things if we embrace
the cult of wokeness the adherents will
just watch because
it's it's you know confirmation bias
it's their religion
so what they do is they inject all of
this into things hoping
that they can create an ideological base
that doesn't
actually find any of this fun or funny
they'll just go
is it isn't this amazing isn't it really
fun because i'll tell you what man i've
seen
comedians and i would not call them
comedians really yeah there was one i
think vice did a segment where they had
a whole comedian and all he did was make
fun of himself
and i'm like first of all i don't know
you and they're in no
like listen rodney dangerfield now that
guy knew self-deprecating humor yeah but
he wasn't
he was very like like raw he wasn't
like pc or anything like that right the
most gruesome like
and it wasn't always self-deprecating
but tell you what i do not want to hear
a guy go
get a load of my white privilege and
then have everyone laugh i'm like that
wasn't a joke you just
you said a buzzword that that the the
the the zealots of your cult are gonna
go hey he's a white prince
he recognizes white privilege clap clap
clap clap there's there's some
there like there are some people who do
what comedy and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna pretend like it's all bad
i'm just saying it's disproportionately
not funny yeah and i'll tell you this
like have you
i'm gonna get real offensive too because
i know that there are some people who
like what
what you have a look i'm listening she's
ready you know we're ready to be
offended do you know where i'm going no
i don't take it he's like have you ever
seen these really cringy like low
quality religious films
oh my gosh my entire upbringing was
spent watching these movies okay
i'm like you're gonna get offended oh no
i'm not offended these things are awful
oh my god what was the worst one you
ever saw the worst one so they're
oh i can't i think i block them from my
memory because they're that bad
but all of them are poorly acted they're
poorly scripted there's no plot
everything's horrible cameron what's his
name kurt cameron
did one that was like really kind of
high budget dude
even the modern ones are just so bad
they have never gotten any better and
i'm like what is wrong with you people
we're losing the culture we're all ready
you're making it worse stop
well yeah well i was gonna say like i've
seen
some of these really low quality like i
can't remember what i was saying
i watched a superhero i think i can't
remember what channel was in chicago
like a religious channel
i grew up i grew up catholic briefly
until i was like i think
10 or 11 we were going to church and
stuff so they they showed us a bunch of
this really hokey stuff and i'm like
the just you you want to talk about a b
movie let's talk about like a z
movie where it's like i don't know
you get the point so they get non-actors
to just read a script but it's more
about the words to try and like this is
scripture
this just i mean like send it out no
it's just they're not film producers
they're not they're not hollywood so
yeah
to be fair right they're making content
to the best of their abilities and
they're not movie studios yes
i would say that their hearts are
definitely in the right place
they just don't know how to produce or
use like right right computers
so you think about these things and then
also think about woke
movies like ghostbusters right i didn't
see it imagine what would happen if you
took some of these
these people and you gave them 200
million dollars to make their movie
they still don't know how to make a
movie they would just make a horrible
movie with 200 million dollars they'd
make ghostbusters 2016.
yeah they would make the like have you
seen ghostbusters 2016. oh no god thank
god i have not
you missing out speaking imagine so like
every male character is always i saw
that mentally deficient
in some capacity or just like it's just
so
so bad dude yeah this is what happens
when you give
you know the zealots access to capital
and they don't know how to do they just
spend the rest on marketing basically so
they make the crappy
still make the crowd they overpay the
actors
they know they just don't know how to
write a movie and if you speak out
against it you get fired so they got a
lot of people on big
contracts and you gotta kind of imagine
if someone was gonna make a new iron man
and they're like we're going to bring
back robert downey jr it's going to be
big
and the guy who's going to run it is
fred the pastor down from you know my
local church
fremont nebraska and he's going to be
like wouldn't it be great
if you know tony goes to confession and
talks about
why he's you know his sins and then
actually you know does
what's it called when you have the ro
when you have the rosary and they they
tell you what to do like
when you confess so i wasn't a catholic
so i don't have any no
sorry yeah you were the catholic friend
we would we would go into confession and
then
you have the rosary and then they would
tell you like yeah praying the rosary
yeah so
professional i don't know and i mean i
mean no disrespect to people who
actually practice these religions i'm
saying
wouldn't it be kind of out of place if
you watched a movie and there were these
weird breaks where it was just like
very on the nose overtly catholic
activities it's like iron man's like in
order to
stop the evil villain mandarin we should
all go to church on sunday there's a
great service and then they spend 20
minutes
that's kind of like i mean i'm obviously
exaggerating but take that
and replace that with the the awokeness
yeah and it's like the men are all
really dumb
and everything is like yeah it's like
it's like watching a religious
propaganda film almost
just as bad yeah with really low
production qualities knowing or
believing this is a religion this new
cult of personality or whatever cult of
of religion cult of race
is that what it is you know i would call
it a non-theistic religion
because it's too widespread and there's
no like there's no pope
of you know there's no cult leader of
wokeness there are priests
you know and i guess you could argue
there's like pope-ish type people but
like you know cults are specifically
worshiping some individual
oh and so yeah so like there's a
i was reading research on colts because
i was talking to a friend and i said
well this is a cult and they said no it
isn't
i looked up the the definition of a cult
like there's a hit
anthropological whatever and it use it
typically requires
an individual who leads it but there are
cults where it's just a culture
because it's so derived from the word
culture i would think or i don't know
um but there's cults of personality
where the person dies and they worship
their picture
and then someone basically is the you
know youtube's a cult of personality
like
you get subscribers people follow you
and it's like they're following your
personality you create a culture
around your personality i don't know
about that actors like brad pitt has a
cult of personality surrounding him
maybe very powerful donald trump but but
but brad pitt's not telling you to like
give your money
to him and something you know cult is an
inheritance actually they're trying to
know they kind of
trying to sell their body like it's a
product that you but it's good
i'll put it this way there's nothing
wrong with having a beer
there's something wrong when having a
beer interferes with your daily life
there's nothing wrong with you know
wanting to follow news about your
favorite celebrity
there's something wrong with doing
nothing but following them and it's
interfering with you appreciating humans
actually a very good thing for society
but getting obsessed with them is not oh
yeah for sure
moderation well i think the the the more
warrior thing
worrying thing is how ideology is
man you know wha wha what were we
watching earlier today i said
christianity in this country is dead
um i think we were watching oh firm we
were watching the firm
yeah i don't remember the context that's
right that's right that's right um the
reason i said that is because
in the 1990s and in a lot of these
movies
so this is really interesting um adam
was jamming
on the show one night and he has that
one song where he says
it's time to confess your sins yeah but
adam's not religious
you know and i was like it's really
interesting that somebody who's not a
practicing religious individual
uses the concept of confessing your sins
because if you went to like
china or india that's not something
culturally relevant to them
they might understand it but it's like
you know i if
imagine if he's saying meditate in a
temple you know and find enlightenment
all right so so we understand these
concepts but confessing your sins is a
very
common cultural thing so we were
watching the firm with tom cruise from
1993
and there was a scene where they were at
a funeral and i was seeing like the
priest
read writes and all that stuff and
that's why i was like
the cultural relevance of this was in a
mainstream tom cruise
major motion picture today
they probably of course still have
things like this but it was interesting
to see like back then how prominent
christianity was even among hollywood
liberals just accepted
right yeah just like a normal thing to
be in a major movie and now
not so much i wonder how much it's it's
like in our subconscious
like um monogamy is like a catholic is
like a christian thing
uh no no i wouldn't well i mean um it's
not monogamy jesus you know
like marriage as we know it is typically
an abrahamic you go to a church like you
can't go to the to the courthouse but
you were gonna say
so i think the fact i think this ties
into adam talking about the idea of
confession
even though he's not religious is
because there are things that go
under human understanding like the
concept that you need to have a man and
a woman and they need to be
together and they need to be united by
like a common chord and a cultural
pressure to keep them together that's
good for families families are good for
the culture
you know all of this stuff is underneath
it's not i don't think it is just
abrahamic religion i think it is part of
the human experience i think there's
something that you can't
avoid i think the feeling of guilt that
we all get sometimes
and the idea that adam brings up about
confessing
is so i don't know like ingrained you
can't escape it and i don't think it is
fully religion i think it's manifest but
the concept of
sin itself is what i mean you think
that's religious no no
yes the word sin is specific to
christianity
isn't it pride lust yes
the word sin itself i mean i don't know
maybe virtues and sins in the catholic
faith
in every faith but is is sin as a word a
concept outside of
christianity gosh i would like to know
that it is yeah it is i believe so
so a sin is just an immoral act
considered to be a transgression against
divine life look up the
etymology the etymology hold on the
entomology
the bug oh is that what i said the
etymology is right etymology yeah
so it's from the latin for guilty
interest yeah so it is not necessarily
religious
it is just part of human nature oh yeah
well there you go you learn something
new every day every religion has its own
sins
like certain religions would look at
like debauchery as a sin whereas
yeah because these things are bad for
the culture debauchery is bad for the
culture people being drunk is bad for
eating eating eating pork you could get
sick exactly and
sugar yeah and that was why god put the
kibosh on it and stuff like shellfish in
leviticus everyone thinks that's crazy
but
when they were eating it it could make
and it often was
sick but then when they learned how to
cook the the it became less relevant
yeah the the hookworm out of it then it
no longer was well the other part too
was that god was that
god was trying to keep his people
separate from other people around them
he was trying to make them separate and
holy and important and special to him
so well do you guys know about the
dawning of the age of aquarius
yeah have you seen zeitgeist yeah uh i
remember watching that where he's like
you know
what's a guy's name peter joseph yeah
yeah i think so yeah he's talking about
how
the the the um judaism was the age of
aries and they blow the ram's horn
and that the next age was the age of
pisces which we're in now and
symbol of the fish and so the new
religion would you know the jesus fish
was a reference to the new age well
we're entering the age of aquarius the
water bearer
so is wokeness the new religion that
will take over i don't think it's gonna
last i don't i just it doesn't seem
sustainable i don't think it can
because it's built on fear and hate like
it's it's not about bringing people
together it's about sounds and awful a
lot like what they used to say about
christianity
no this is a little bit different so i
know i was raised in christianity and i
know there are people who have left the
church
violently who say that it's nothing but
fear and guilt and there is a bit of
that if you're not doing it right
but i think that basing it basing
something on fear and guilt
is in fact untenable i think that
christianity is not based on fear or
guilt it's based on a whole
of a healthy respect for divine
providence for god and for other humans
and like jesus if you break it down the
christ consciousness
is like that's a good thing but when you
organize a religion of business around
it and try and profit off of
the concept is when it starts to get
dangerous yeah you involve human greed
and stuff
yeah it's a problem yep the the very
simple story
of a of a dude who helped other dudes
dude if we could just behave like jesus
like if everyone started behaving like
that
that's like the whole point of
christianity they're just like just
behave like this guy he was great he was
the son of god you're not perfect but do
the best you can and ask for forgiveness
forgiveness turn the other cheek i would
love it if the scw's would turn the
other cheek i would love it
everyone did good sir i couldn't help
but notice that you said a naughty word
on twitter well
i ask that you humbly take into
consideration but i will turn the other
cheek and i will move on
i'd be like how nice and they should get
likes for that if you could somehow get
rewarded for
for not dissing on someone but dude
humans are flawed
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8pm so come back to check us
out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you